thank you
it was one of those things okay I can't
take it back now it's like not final yep
no backseats weary we are so excited for
this I can't believe I even said yes
sorry she's mid prep for Super Bowl 57's
halftime show and we're hearing
Rihanna's excited and the happiest she's
ever been what did I just get myself
into because the Super Bowl is one of
the biggest stages in the world and the
singers got the best audience while
gearing up for game day
et Source says her man ASAP Rocky and
their baby boy have been attending her
rehearsals
and Rihanna is really focused on work
and wants to wow her fans she's putting
her all into it you know what I want to
incorporate
a lot of culture I want to incorporate
different aspects of entertainment and
things that I just enjoy and bring it to
the stage and her prep goes beyond vocal
warm-ups The Source ads Rihanna's on a
strict diet and trying to eat clean and
be healthy it's an Entertainer's dream
to be on a stage like that but it's
nerve-wracking you want to get it right
you know everybody's watching
and they're rooting for you
it's been
290 days Rihanna the details follow last
week's trailer poking fun at Rihanna's
long-awaited next album we waited
it's been six years since the nine-time
Grammy winner
and where have you been we've been
impatiently waiting for last time
[Music]
you're gonna kill it that's the homie
man We Love You Rihanna who's also
excited a halftime show veteran I feel
like you you could give advice because
you've done this before advice
and it's gonna be amazing is what the
whole world wants oh man I'm just as
excited as you guys and ASAP Rocky tells
it the Navy's in for an epic show I'm so
glad that my lady's back making music
again and whatnot and getting back out
there you know and it's just incredible
the Super Bowl is huge I'm excited I'm
more excited than everybody else
honestly